Thank You Tina I did graduate with an
engineering degree but not right here
because there was no right here when Amy
and I graduated I don't know what was
right here but it was not the
engineering school what you guys are
experiencing here at Stanford as
undergrads and graduates is way more
buffed at in high tech than when I was
in school but it's really great to be
back on campus it's it's every time I
come back to Stanford I am blown away by
just how Stanford just keeps amping it
up and up and she just keeps upping the
game more and more to the point where
you know I I don't know how we can
actually get any more influential so I'm
really proud when I come back to
Stanford and I have that that common
feeling that lots of alums have like wow
I don't know if I can get into Stanford
now given how talented all you guys are
but anyway thank you guys for having me
here tonight this is this is super
exciting I was I was thinking this was
going to be an intimate little sit on a
stool in front of a small group of
people and have an intimate conversation
this is a little bit more than I then I
bargained for Tina did warn me what was
going to happen here she kept saying
it'll get downloaded 15,000 times a day
and now I'm super nervous because all
these cameras are everywhere but let me
see if I can't tell you guys my story
hopefully not make it a boring story
hopefully make it a story that you can
learn from and Tina also said don't just
tell your story she gave me a bunch of
instructions make it module or I don't
even know what that means but try to
teach some lessons at the same time or
try to glean what your let what lessons
you have taken away as you look back on
your career okay so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to tell my story which I'm
gonna call power to the people okay
that's my story power to the people and
it'll become apparent what I'm talking
about hopefully and then I'm going to
talk I'm gonna have three main lessons
that hang off of this and three loops
off of this power to the people's story
and those lessons are going to be
couched
couple stories themselves the first is
gonna be Pygmalion the second is going
to be the Wizard of Oz and the third is
going to be Keanu Reeves okay that's the
only one other references nobody gets
okay but I'll explain so power to the
people
Pygmalion Wizard of Oz Keanu Reeves here
we go all right so I graduated in 1989
with an industrial engineering degree
actually a general engineering degree :
industrial economics because I went to
Florence and studied for a semester and
that or for a quarter and that took me
off track so I couldn't actually get an
ie degree so I made up my own
engineering degree which was a terrific
thing about Stanford and I took that
degree and I after a short stint in
consulting made my way to Microsoft okay
Microsoft only had about 3000 people
when I when I joined so it was a
relatively small company and I was a
product manager of DOS 5 nobody not even
any chuckle of recognition we don't have
anybody who even knows with DOS isn't
his operating system and it was the
first time Microsoft actually marketed
an operating system upgrade before that
there never been an operating system
upgrade and so I was brought in as a
product manager to try to sell operating
system upgrades to regular consumers
with pcs such that they would upgrade to
their computers the killer feature we
had for DAWs 5 does anybody know it all
right we're not gonna rock geeky enough
you can't no Haim MDOT sis we broke the
640k barrier of the Intel chip so we got
it we could run programs in high memory
anyway okay we're not gonna do any any
geeky stuff but the point is I was a
product manager and I traveled a lot I
was a business traveler and it was it
was really frustrating for me to deal
with the corporate travel agency I had
to plan a trip from Seattle where I was
working I had to stop in Denver I to go
to Buffalo New York to Denver I mean to
Dallas and then back to Seattle okay
this was a really complicated thing for
me to plan with a corporate travel agent
and we had to do it on the phone and I
would call him or her
on the phone and I'd and I'd hear this
clicking on the keyboard okay of this I
knew I know I knew she was looking at a
screen as she was telling me fairs and
hotels and everything like that and yet
I couldn't see that screen for myself I
knew I kind of wanted to jump through
the phone turn the screen my way and do
it myself okay this is a you know
putting barriers between people and
information is unsustainable in the
world of technology and I recognized at
that point that there was a real
opportunity to give power to the people
and take that system that the travel
agent was using and put it in front of
people with their PCs and it just so
happens that the internet was the
graphical web hadn't quite happened yet
but the internet was just happening and
there were these consumer online
services like America Online anybody
remember that CompuServe prodigy I was a
user of these services and I knew that
consumers were using online services and
getting access to information so while I
was at Microsoft and I was a product
manager and I was a kind of frustrated
entrepreneur I knew I knew someday I
wanted to be an entrepreneur I saw this
problem in this opportunity and the
lightbulb of an idea for a startup went
off in my head and this is at a time
when Microsoft was pretty small I had
opportunities multiple times a year to
get in front of Bill Gates and give him
updates on whatever project I was
working on and I pitched the idea at the
next meeting of actually building an
electronic travel agent and putting that
power of information in the hands of
regular people as a startup idea to Bill
I actually thought it wouldn't be a
software business and that Microsoft
wouldn't be that interested in it I said
fund me on the outside and I'll go
fulfill my entrepreneurial dreams and so
I it was kind of a VC interaction that I
was that I was thinking of it as and he
laughed and he said who you're gonna
hire I was twenty five or six years old
I was pretty young and so he said
started inside of Microsoft and if it
works and wants to be separate from
Microsoft then we'll think about
spinning it off okay and so that was how
Expedia was born when I pitched the idea
one of the things that that really bill
like a whole a whole lot about the idea
one was that we were gonna build on PCs
what was being run on mainframes in the
travel industry and he liked he liked
PCs doing the work that mainframes were
doing but I'll he also saw in me that I
had a really big idea and a big dream I
went in saying we can one day become the
largest seller of travel in the world
because I recognized that this power to
the people technology had the
opportunity to catalyze an industrial
revolution in the travel industry a
giant industry and that if we could
short-circuit the connection between the
suppliers and the consumers and put them
together one-to-one without anybody else
in between that the consumers were gonna
storm the Bastille and take over the
industry okay
and so I had this B hag this big hairy
audacious goal that was become the
largest seller of travel in the world
someday by helping everyone everywhere
make and take better trips that was my
that was my big dream and so in this
first power to the people's story that
I'm telling of the first this first
startup this was a startup inside the
belly of the beast of Microsoft my
takeaway lesson here is the first lesson
and that's a pigment this is the
Pygmalion myth lesson this this is have
great expectations
great expectations beget great results
and at the the sociologists here at
Stanford have a a human behavior name
for this and they call it the big
million effect the story of Pygmalion is
the story of a it's a Greek myth and
it's the story of a sculptor who
sculpted a statue of a woman and she was
so beautiful and he loved her so much
that she actually came to life and they
were together very sweet
there been lots of movies my fair lady
the one of the great all-time 80s geek
flicks is the same story can anybody
name it it's a kind of a geeky one weird
science these two kids use a cat what
looks like a CAD program to build a
virtual woman and she actually comes to
life okay anyway this is a repeatable
myth that shows up over and over again
but the effect is that the sociological
effect is that great expectations beget
great results all right there is a book
called good to great that's a business
kind of a business school book by a guy
Jim Collins Thank You Tina Jim Collins
good to great and it is basically this
same idea
aim high and when you aim high and have
big hairy audacious goals more often
than not they are somewhat
self-fulfilling because once you free
yourself to dream big and think big you
end up attracting people around you and
joining teams of like-mindedness and
human ingenuity is such that you figure
out how to actually make it so all right
so that's my little lesson number one
detour the Pygmalion effect and that
feeds back into the story of Expedia and
I'll conclude quickly with that story
this first power to the people story by
saying that Expedia is now the largest
seller of travel in the world sells over
seventy billion dollars a year in in
travel Bill Gates and Steve Ballmer who
was my boss at my last boss at Microsoft
did honor their their pledge to consider
spinning off Expedia from Microsoft when
I went and asked them for 100 million
dollars to spend on television
advertising and they said no and I said
well the public markets this was 1999
1999 was the first Internet bubble
pets.com went public in 1999 ok anybody
could go public in 1999 including
Expedia anybody and I knew we could
raise a bunch of money from the public
markets and to spend on television
advertising with which we could use to
help turbocharged our our ride to
becoming the largest seller of travel
world and and that worked so when we do
Q&A we can talk about the IPO process
and going public if you're if you're
interested is something I've taken more
than one company public and been part of
many others as they go public including
Netflix I was on that board when it was
private so for over 15 years so that's
that's a that's a topic we could talk
about but at that point Expedia spun off
I was a 32 year old CEO of a public
company my management team was quite
young all around all around my age or
younger we were thrown right into the
fire and it was a wild time it was
Expedia turned out to be a fantastic
business so when the bubble burst and
everything went down and crashed Expedia
crashed with it but we had a real
business we were profitable and we grew
right we grew right through it that that
story will conclude I was it was a
public company for a few years on its
own it did was immensely successful but
it was public and a buyer came along a
guy named Barry Diller who was a media
mogul who was getting out of the media
industry and into the internet and he
came along and made a gigantic offer to
buy the company and we didn't have much
it was such a good offer we didn't have
much of a choice other than to to sell
the company for this big offer this was
in around 2003 and at that point we sold
the company and at that point I left and
and and started doing other things all
right so let me push pause for a sec and
relocate ourselves on the kind of map of
my of the non Q&A portion of the chat
all right so the my story of startups
there's a common thread through all of
them and that is power to the people
okay and this is this kind of
fundamental ring zero acknowledgment
that freedom is primal that we want
control we want all of the information
we can we want to make decisions for
ourselves especially ones that are
entertaining and ones that are
financially important we want to make
these decisions ourselves ok there's
there is no industry where we the people
we consumers don't want to have
more information in our fingertips so
that we can be better informed okay
and so Expedia is an instant instance of
a start-up that kind of typifies this
this transparency of information idea
and it ended up catalyzing a new
industrial a technology driven
industrial revolution in the travel
industry and the travel industry has
never been the same sense okay so that's
that's module one all right let me get a
little sip of water
all right so story two is that I went
after we sold Expedia and I left I had
three very little kids and a wife and we
had been working really hard for a long
time she's a doctor and we decided to
take a little break which is a sub
lesson I didn't highlight this one but
we we moved to Italy for a year and we
lived in Florence with our three little
kids and you can close your eyes maybe
you've been to Florence or been to Italy
I've been to Tuscany imagine the Rolling
Hills the vines the glass of wine in
your hands the bowl of pasta right in
front of you okay as you build your
careers and you guys do things this
right here that you that I'm I'm trying
to this picture I'm painting that you're
seeing and smelling and tasting is a
really important part of life and and
success in your careers you really
really do need to take a breather and
and give yourself a little space and
time to think and relax and focus on
other things I actually find that for me
my very best ideas happen for me when I
am on a surfboard or a snowboard or in
the middle of the desert at Burning Man
where I've been with with a me in the
front row here excuse me I'm sorry maybe
I shouldn't do that it's on video nobody
knows your last name so giving yourself
think space and time sheltered from this
incessant barrage of feeds did
little feeds that you all have that we
all now have in our lives giving
yourself a little shelter from that in
space and time to to focus wholly on
something else I actually find that is
when the best when I actually do my best
thinking about everything so make sure
you make time for that so anyway I did
that I tried to find my inner
Michelangelo I took a life drawing class
which was pretty cool if you haven't
taken a life drawing class do it it's
interesting you'll find out a lot about
yourself
I did that I tried writing I wanted to
find my inner artist and do something
else and pivot my whole life I was only
I don't know how old I was 35 or 36 at
the time turns out I couldn't stop the
business business oriented and startup
oriented ideas coming at me and I had a
lot of inbound interest for to get
involved in things and I was involved in
some other things and I really couldn't
get out they kind of sucked me back in
and so I moved back from Italy and
immediately started thinking about new
things all right
one of the things I was thinking about
was actually becoming a venture
capitalist there lot many people I know
and love are venture capitalists I came
pretty close to moving back down here
from Seattle and working as a venture
capitalist of benchmark capital and at
the last minute I decided not to but I
decided to start up a new company with a
friend of mine who I had met at who I'd
met at Stanford a guy named Lloyd Frank
he was a year a year ahead of me at
Stanford who's maybe 88 from Seattle we
had met at Stanford he had gone to work
at my current to the same high school
Lakeside that Bill Gates and Paul Allen
the founders of Microsoft went to
although they are eight or nine years
apart in age they didn't really know
each other but they'd gone to the same
running school and their moms knew each
other and Lloyd's mom knew Bill's mom
and Lloyd's mom said to Bill's mom my
son likes computers and Villas mom said
so does mine
we should get them together and so Lloyd
at age 13 got together with Bill Gates
Microsoft was about 25 people at the
time and Lloyd went to work part-time
for Microsoft when he was 14 years old
actually because nobody none of the guys
none of the guys and gals at Microsoft
was mostly guys at the time wanted to
answer support calls it was really
support letters and so they had this kid
from high school come in and he had to
answer the answer the support letters it
was kind of funny anyway so he worked at
Microsoft successively every summer
after that and then went to work for
Microsoft after college and he was a key
part of the team that built Expedia
inside of Microsoft and when I came back
from Italy we were sharing an office he
had left Expedia too we were sharing an
office just brainstorming ideas and it
just so happened that like when I was a
product manager in planning my trips we
were sharing an office and shopping for
homes because he was in family expansion
mode and we needed to find a new home
and this is in 2004 something like that
2005 and it's 2005 the web has been
around for a long time now and it was
unbelievable to us how little access a
little information on what's for sale
and about homes that we could access to
make an informed decision we're like
this is the most important financial
decision of our lives you know homes are
the biggest asset that most people have
if you're lucky enough to have one and
and yet we can't get basic information
to determine what a house is actually
worth what's the square footage you know
or can I see pictures of the inside of
it what are the tax records for this for
this house a house is for sale we would
go on the web and look it's for sale
listings on the web and they didn't even
have addresses listed okay so so you
couldn't even go by and take a look at
the house and in the physical world and
this is all because the people that ran
the industry at the time wanted to to
hold that information and keep it keep
it to themselves behind big walls to
keep it from people so that they could
be the arbiters of the information and
they could be the distributors of the
information and they could share the
information only that that they wanted
to share and so we looked at that and we
said well how
lucky are we there is another
opportunity to do a part of the people
start up we can actually tear down those
well maybe we can tear down those walls
and connect ourselves our sisters our
mothers all the people we know connect
them with all this information that we
know they want so that they can make
much better decisions about this most
important financially and most dear
emotionally decision that they make now
most of you probably haven't bought a
house yet hopefully you will someday and
you'll understand even more but you kind
of have a sense for how emotionally and
financially important homes are and so
Zillow was Zillah was born so this is
the second the second kind of power to
the people start up and this is in this
is in 2005 and our mission there was
very similar to what our you know our
Pygmalion mission or be hag there was
very similar to what it had been in
travel we wanted to become the largest
real estate market place in the world
where we would we build the most trusted
in vibrant market place we'd help people
find better homes and improve their
lives
okay it was a pretty it's been a pretty
simple mission and we wanted to be the
largest and it turned that was in 2005
that we launched it turns out today
Zillah group is the largest real estate
market place in the world we get about
170 million unique visitors a month to
our brands our brands include Zillow
Trulia and Street Easy those are our
three biggest brands we also have hot
pads which is a little smaller that some
of you may know or run into soon as you
start getting apartments and the the
lesson I want to tell about the about
from Zillow the little lesson is Wizard
of Oz okay Wizard of Oz so Wizard of Oz
is not a current movie or play but most
of you guys know the story right Wizard
of Oz there are three main characters of
The Wizard of Oz all right and the let
the lesson here is about people and
teams okay a lesson here is about how do
you know you're getting in with the
right a lot of people as you as you
embark on your careers and how do you
evaluate who is going to be you know
who do you think exhibits those those
really rare the really rare combination
of leadership qualities and I use this
Wizard of Oz shorthands the three main
characters of The Wizard of Oz were the
Scarecrow the Cowardly Lion and the Tin
Man all right and each one was seeking
something that they were missing
this was their quest and The Wizard of
Oz they were going to the Emerald City
to visit the man behind the curtain the
all great and powerful mighty wizard who
was going to grant them each a wish and
the wish for the Scarecrow was that he
had brains all right thank you good
getting some participation brains okay
so lesson number one as you look for
people in teams and companies is they're
smart they exhibit brains they have they
have brains this seems like a simple
thing it's not actually all that simple
and it's not actually easy to discern
many times especially early early in
your careers okay but this is super
important and in the information economy
the economy that most of you are going
into the there aren't factories and
trucks and trains and and and and
there's not as much capital physical
capital and assets for companies these
days all the companies I'm involved with
the assets are all human assets it's
human capital and the work product of
people's brains are the assets of the
company code and brands and ideas okay
and so joining a company and joining up
with people who are smart is really
super important and having a work
environment that takes care of smart
people is really important all right so
that's scarecrow number one brains the
Cowardly Lion what did he seek courage
all right good
someone's gonna break out into song here
soon I'm sure all right courage people
and teams have to have courage all right
it can't be crazy courage because too
much courage like if you have it's if
there's these are three legs of a stool
and you have too much courage and not
enough brains the stool tips over right
because you're being stupid you're being
stupid Lee risk loving you want to have
courage but you want to take take smart
bets all right but it's an it's an
obvious one and
the third and perhaps the most important
is what the Tin Man saw it he was
seeking heart all right
heart this is the third leg of the stool
it's really important that you join
teams of people who care about people
all right
again it's people who are driving the
new economy it's the work product of
your brains and life is too short to
fall in with people who don't care about
people and if you happen to fall in with
people who are super passionate about
something and we're on a mission to
change the world in some unbelievable
way that is even better because we all
actually don't really want jobs we want
to be part of something bigger than
ourselves to change the world so that we
can put our little dent in the universe
all right so that we can actually change
change the world for the better that is
what I mean by heart and passion and
those are the three legs of the stool as
back coming back to the story now of
Zillow as I started Zillow I was really
lucky to have the whole founding team
come from all people I'd worked with
before at Expedia every everyone and
including several Stanford grads
everyone so our CTO at Expedia became
the CTO of Zillow even though we had
zero employees and there's a long long
list of people including including my
partner would okay so to wrap Story
number two of Zillow and then I'll move
on and we'll get to cute we'll get to
questions power to the people Story
number two Zillow did really well we
launched in 2005 we launched with the
Zestimate which was an estimated market
value of every home in the country that
we've dropped on every roof in the
country we updated every night so it had
this amazing emotional kind of real
estate porn appeal to it people wanted
to see what homes were worth that was a
completely novel thing drew so many
people on the first day that we launched
that the site went over and didn't come
back up for a day and a half okay which
we made a good PR story and said we're
so popular it fell over so everybody
came back later so that was our initial
feature and now Zillow is a is a is a
giant marketplace we took it
the business grew we took it public
about six years ago
so Zillow group is a pub
company now just like Expedia is a
public company we have about a billion
dollars in revenues so it's like a you
know it's become a it's become a real
company I'm executive chairman there I
ran it for the first six years of
existence I was the CEO but then I kind
of kicked myself upstairs and I'm
executive chairman there now all right
and that's an ongoing concern we have
lots of lands to conquer on that one and
that's fun
I'm gonna curtail my third story of
Glassdoor the third power to the people
startup that I've been lucky enough to
put together with a really good friend
who was the development manager for me
at Expedia I hired him right out of
getting a master's in computer science
at Stanford he got a named Robert Holman
he after he left Expedia he came to me
he said let's start you know what do you
got you got any ideas let's start
something I said sure yeah let's let's
talk and we had a I shared with him a
story and we brainstormed and we came up
with the idea for glass door and glass
doors now one of the largest job search
sites if you don't know what it is you
can find out the salaries it's kind of
TripAdvisor for jobs you can find out
the salaries and titles and experience
levels of any job pretty much anywhere
in the world and it's all done by an
anonymous open survey so tens of
millions of people come into the to the
site and the service and they they say
here's my job title here's my salary
here's what it's like to work here here
the cultures and values of the company I
approve or disapprove of the leadership
on the CEO so it's an open survey it's
just great great transparency
information power to the people
information and it's transforming the
job business I'm the chairman there that
one is actually in the Bay Area hasn't
gone public yet but I'm hoping to get
you know the team is hoping to get that
public here sometime soon knock on wood
okay I guess the last lesson from
hanging off of that story I was going to
be Keanu Reeves
all right Keanu Reeves Keanu Reeves has
been in he's such an actor I mean if the
fact that he's never gotten best actor
this is just robbery
I mean point Point Break that we should
have gotten it for that
but the one I'm referring to here is
Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure who's
seen that alright alright come on wow
this is one you got to put on your list
alright Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
which I saw when I was an undergraduate
at Stanford down the road here on El
Camino I forget the name of the theater
I saw it for the first time a really
silly movie that actually is turns out
to be super important it's full of
really interesting philosophy
and the kind of core philosophy for Bill
and Ted aside from their wild stallions
and their guitar riffs and their San
Dimas high school football rules anyway
the thing that they said over and over
again was be excellent to each other and
it was a ha ha funny from these two
skateboard riding kids who were
traveling through time but be excellent
to each other actually is really
important I think especially important
now if you're following the news like
people's capacity to not be excellent to
each other is infinite okay it's
infinite I never put it this way I've
never put it this way before this be
excellent to each other I always used to
say no I haven't no
policy I don't care how smart you are I
don't care how talented you are I don't
care how much Drive you have if you're
an you're not on my team okay we
we respect each other we are excellent
to each other and I'm adding I'm saying
no and now I'm appending no
scumbags because it turns out they're a
lot more scumbags then then I that I had
anticipated before so no no
scumbags be excellent to each other and
when you're excellent to each other
it pays huge dividends because people
you work that you're going to school
with right now and that you work with
earlier and your careers they come back
they come back around and the store each
of my stories but Glassdoor as well as a
story of people that I worked with and I
was excellent to and who were excellent
to me coming back around and doing new
cool things together alright so you know
I I never put this together but I so
much Stanford because so much of the
foundation of my network actually was
hatched right here and I guess that's a
lesson to be excellent to the people
right here because a lot of the people
you're going
school with and work and working on
projects with or you know playing
ultimate frisbee with or whatever it is
these are the people that you know are
you're going to be working you may be
working with them throughout your career
and there's really are some really
talented people here there are some
and scumbags too but there's
some really talented people here and so
be excellent to each other and it will
pay dividends alright
so power to the people
Pygmalion the lesson of Pygmalion is
great expectations but get great results
alright Wizard of Oz which is brains
courage and heart and Bill and Ted
Kennedy's be excellent to each other
all right questions we can talk about I
didn't talk anything about Netflix
we can talk about that I know it's
really topical I'm just a board director
there so it's not a company I started
shoot you know but it's one I'm lucky
enough to be to have been involved with
for a long time okay I'll kick it off
yes if there were burning questions so
I'm really passionate about what leaders
do to build cultures I mean you talk
about the importance of the culture what
are the levers you have at your disposal
for building a culture of innovation and
Trust yeah that you use okay so so what
are the levers I have as a leader at my
disposal to build a culture of
innovation and trust and respect and
success I'll append to that you know the
first one is the people point okay you
gotta you gotta get in with the right
people okay and so when you're small the
people point never goes away it's really
important but when you're small you know
everybody and so a lot of the more
Dilbert II processes kind of big company
processes they don't come into play
necessarily when you have a small team
of people okay it's when you pass the
Dunbar unit of 150 people probably or
thereabouts when you can note you as
this CEO you as the engineer you as the
HR
person can't possibly know everybody and
know everything that's going on and now
you need to put in place a lot of these
what younger people might view as
bureaucratic or diliberti you guys know
what Dilbert is right all right anyway
like joking at big companies processes
and an infrastructure in place and part
of that is laying out a really
well-defined mission talking about
values and then actually living those
values in in the company and reinforcing
them and every possible chance you have
to communicate and so so the CEO of
Zillow group is a guy named Spencer
rozhkov who was just unbelievable and he
has his his mission thing that everybody
says before every meeting and he has the
the six values of the company stuff like
move fast think big you know and you
know those are blazoned on the walls and
those pervade his communications that is
one technique and if it's abided by it
works really really well another one
that I actually liked its kind of
Dilbert II as well is that that
everybody does this kind of fun
personality test at Zillow group at
least and every company has some
different mechanism and the personality
test ends up it's kind of fun everybody
likes to answer a bunch of questions
about themselves and be told why they're
so special and different and it turns
out that no matter what your strengths
are it's special in different in
additive which is true it turns out a
diversity of personality is really
important in a corporate environment and
those things are translated into a
series of colored bricks that sit on
people's desks at Zillow group and if
it's red on top that means this person
leads with red energy they're
competitive you know they want to they
want to you know be told things quickly
and then get out of my face but then the
people that have the green brick on top
which is which are they just kind of
want to get along with everyone
everybody to get along with each other
and cooperate and it's a really
interesting mechanism I found for people
who are clashing with other people to
look at their personality profile and
say oh yeah okay that person you know
Amy is the green on top person so I'm
gonna have to actually be
behave a little differently you know
these are silly sounding corporate
offending things that are really
important as companies get big who else
yes not good it's not the end so when
you had your time for frustration or
maybe feeling lonely and like no one was
backing me up how did you keep going
what did you tell yourself if it's not
good it's not the end yeah okay and then
how do you keep going uh Ricky Bobby if
you're not first you're last but I
didn't say that
I must have been drunk guys I'm seeing
it's Netflix I see too many movies
alright here's here's my answer to that
Mount Rainier is in CL Mount Rainier is
a 14,500 foot volcano that looms over
seattle if you've been there you've seen
it on the right day you've seen it it's
really astounding the way this giant
mountain looms and a lot of people look
at it and they want to climb it we have
a human urge to climb the summit implant
our flag and be on top of the mountain
and this is a metaphor I'm gonna use to
answer your question for the mission of
your company or or your project or
whatever you're working on okay if you
have a clear mission and it's
inspirational and you maybe have a team
of people or maybe it's just you you're
trying to get to that summit but it's a
clear mission and it's good and you
understand it then on your way there's
your hiking with your team when it's
stormy or you're trying to crop make a
bad river crossing and you can't see the
mountain and things feel lonely and bad
well if that image of Mount Rainier the
summit of Mount Rainier is clearly in
your mind you know where you're headed
and you know what you want and you know
it's good you get through its when you
don't know where you're going that when
you run into hard times you end up
despondent and you give up next
realizing you mentioned power to the
people multiple times and I'm like so
you mentioned that people want more
information yeah like they wanna make
their own decisions I think they needed
this concept of things like machine
learning where convenience is of utmost
importance we all want to get a fit or
one time this is just to be mean for
them so they do without the hassle so is
it fair to you or new thing that this is
shift in focus since your companies have
been launched like quite some time back
okay
I think I get the question I'm not gonna
repeat it exactly but I'll paraphrase it
and I'll say you say people want all
this information to make decisions for
themselves but they're being overloaded
with information but now we have machine
learning and we can do it for them I
like that that's good that's next phase
that's what's going on we are drowning
in information we have too much and next
level stuff I mean the class before this
was machine learning for 32 or something
which I missed but we employ machine
learning a lot of my and a lot of my
companies it is to actually
synthetically be able to sort sift and
analyze and make decisions for you
people want a really smart assistance
and there is such a deluge of data that
having intelligent synthetic
intelligence be able to sort sift and
recommend for us and maybe anticipate
for us is super interesting and we want
everything really we tend to want
everything really fast
we want it now this thing has trained us
to - that we can push a button and have
it show up right here right now you know
the uber vacation of everything Netflix
has done the same thing I want to watch
it now then I want to watch the next one
okay I want my groceries now I want to
buy my house now I want my job now okay
and this is what's going on I think
especially for commodity like things
where you're willing to delegate the
purchase of things or the decisions of
things to an intelligence that's what
that's where it's happening first but
this is kind of the next phase of taking
data and turning it into intelligence
and as you you know as you guys are
looking at opportune
for your career for your business
careers or academic her as this is a
really fertile place to look yeah
yes do you find that your private
companies have different incentive
structures than public companies turn
decisions we stockholders okay do you
find your private companies behave
differently from your public companies
because they're public not mine not mine
I'm a firm believer that being having a
public company when it's ready to be
public is a huge advantage it gives you
strategic optionality and optionality is
valuable when you have a public security
you're able to do things with that
public security like raise money and do
acquisitions compensate people in that
that offers strategic flexibility and
strategic optionality is is is valuable
now the downside to being a public
company is you have to report every
quarter and a lot of people especially
here in the valley think that that's
like you know some awful thing like some
torture fest and you know we shouldn't
pay any attention to these investors and
you know screw that I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna do that maybe they demand all
this short-term stuff well for weak
companies and weak leadership or you
know professional manager lead companies
that's that is that is the case but the
company the public companies that I'm
involved with tend to be run by founders
all of them are run by founders
sometimes as in the case with Zilla
group we have a class of stock that
gives us voting control and those those
enable us to behave more like a private
company and make decisions for the long
for the long term and the shareholders
that that that know us and believe in us
can come along for the ride long term
even if we have to do short term things
that hurt profitability they know we're
doing it for the long term because we're
in it for the long term because we
control the company and so I believe
having a founder lead company that
or founder like lead company that has
some some control provisions to to free
people free free these companies up to
make long-term decisions is the optimal
combination personally yeah yes to be
excellent to each other in a tip you can
share always yes how do you be excellent
to each other okay
so I think this is especially true
because a lot of you are in tech a lot
of your engineers and maybe many of you
will go work for tech companies okay and
there actually is a class of tech
company where the engineers kind of rule
the roost and that may sound appealing
to you because you're an engineer and by
rule the roost I've been in these
companies before and by rule the roost I
mean look down their noses at and kind
of disrespect other functions at the
company like sales or marketing or
operations or IT HR these are all just
around to support me the engineer I'm
the god engineer I'm exaggerating here
alright but having a company where there
is a explicit or implicit class system
amongst employees is no bueno
okay that is absolutely not good it can
work for some companies for a while but
it ain't a happy place to work all right
and it's suboptimal now it's suboptimal
I think about it as spokes in a wheel a
wheel is true and spins beautifully with
with with very little friction when all
the spokes are tightened to the same
strength and then the wheel turns it
doesn't turn if spokes are missing or
they're shorter or what-have-you and
that's kind of how I feel about all of
these different functions at a company
they have to all be firing on this
firing on on on all cylinders to make
the machine
really work and I believe as we enter
this kind of next phase of Technology
oriented company and startup that's
being created I believe that the the two
geeks in a garage story are going to
become fewer and fewer suffer me at the
beginning of the web the web was a flat
open egalitarian space to geeks in a
garage really could start anything and
as long as they were discovered by Yahoo
or later Google you know both Stanford
startups magic things can happen all
right is that how you feel about the the
web and opportunity today is that is
that the landscape we see today out
there a we is it is it this great open
flat web of opportunity it's really not
it's really not it is the art there are
these massive companies that control
masses of eyeballs and traffic have huge
influence over over what people see and
what people do and what ads people see
and they get to decide by and large what
companies become successful and what
don't and so when you go into if you're
going into a start-up my advice now
would be make sure that you know marry a
marketer if you're an engineer marry a
marketer how about marketer as a
boyfriend or a girlfriend okay
have that market or be part of your
company because you're gonna need to be
super clever about how to get your
product in front of people and then the
next person you should get to know is
the perp the money person and the next
person you should get to know is the
operations person anyway you need a full
team to be discovered it's much much
harder these days I believe to break
through the clutter and the noise than
it was back when I started Expedia which
is which is too bad now that'll be the
case until something new comes along you
know maybe there will be a new web I
can't really envision it some people
think blockchain that's what you know
blockchain is going to be the basis of a
new wide open web and you know maybe
maybe I think more likely Alexa and
Google home and these voice voice
intelligences that are proliferating
right now
more likely those are gonna succeed and
as those succeed the choke point gets
even narrower for companies to fit
through okay
expect consumer oriented comes you've
got to come through the voice and the
voice is not a full screen with lots of
links on it the voice is one answer
probably okay where should I go for
dinner
what movies should I see get me airline
tickets you know find me a house like
you get one answer in these things so I
actually think about this a lot I think
power is actually concentrating in the
hands of these mega mega global
distributors now not dispersing okay
I'll get off my soapbox find another
student question what what's a piece of
advice
or student at Stanford about how to
prioritize their time I mean yeah if
you're sitting in this class you're
already way better than I was when you
when I was at Stanford I really I look
back and I I like regret I shouldn't do
that but I kind of regret what a dope I
was and how I spent my time I like
played Super Mario Brothers as video
games you know for hours and I could
have been coming to this class and
seeing me you know
the fact that you're here though says
that you're not you're not that person
but I mean I would go back first of all
I think I probably would have taken a
gap year so that I would have matured
but we're too late for that here you
know but being aggressive about
squeezing all the juice out of this let
this orange you know that you have here
you got your hands around a resource you
have no idea how magical it is how much
is available to you to tap into and you
know there was the Stanford Golf Course
you know I wasn't a golfer but I should
have learned how to play golf like I
like trying to learn now it's super
frustrating but like I got a lot of time
as a student here as you do like I could
have gone and learned and played golf on
the golf course what a dummy you know I
could have gone surfing and learned how
to surf I was from the East Coast and
all these guys are surfing I'm like well
I don't know you know it would have been
I don't know why didn't I ask somebody
to teach me how to surf anyway deuce do
more stuff yeah okay well my views on
real estate in the next two years and
where this is the future is off yeah so
so Zillow is like the Bloomberg of real
estate information and I am NOT the
spokesperson for that all that data so I
can't give you a great prognostication
but Zillow itself provides you with a
lot of good stuff we're like feeding the
fed and and feeding all these industry
groups all the data we have but
generally speaking it's pretty hot real
estate market you know especially here
and there good aspects of that and bad
aspects of it but we're you know well
above the bubble levels we we hit before
the global financial crisis there a
bunch of social dynamic things that are
driving real estate prices in places
like San Francisco that you know
probably are not sustainable but
generally speaking the real estate
market is immensely healthy right now
for for Zillow group we we have you know
we're a billion in sales right now the
company is valued at about eight billion
dollars it's a big company already we
have 3,000 people that the
but I believe we've just set the table
for for the main event like we just set
the table for dinner we've we've we've
brought transparency to this giant
industry and yet not much has changed
yet things have got to change and so we
see a ton of kind of the Oubre fication
of you know weights and you've probably
never bought a house but it's like
really hard to buy a house and like
signing all these documents and all this
time and all these people with the fans
at taking money from you and title
insurance and anyway there's all this
cruft and software can be a great
leveler of cruft in the long term and so
that's kind of the next the next phase
and so there's a we see a ton of
opportunity in in making the whole
process much easier for the buyer and
the seller ultimately yeah yes why do
you think red fin hasn't taken off yet
red fin why hasn't red fin taken off yet
it's it's it's you know it's actually
doing okay
it's another Seattle company but it's a
brokerage company and it's a discount
brokerage I'm not sure I'm not sure but
I you know they do some pretty they do
some pretty interesting things brokerage
models are inherently more limited from
a growth perspective weird Zillow Group
is a marketplace and platform okay
we're an open marketplace we're not
trying we don't we don't have real
estate agents that work that work for us
so we're not limited to that
so they've chosen a little bit different
business model but it's a it's a
well-run company everything and I live
here and also I live in Japan and this
one Bernie if you could share some
lessons learned for go Hawks fan Jeong
somewhat well global expansion global
expansion do you have any and maybe one
more question is that if you have any
insight for real estate market in Japan
or how you do I don't think you have
we're not in Japan right so Zillah group
is join but it's my only company that's
just us um
well the wonderful thing about the the
internet and technology is that it makes
the world much smaller it brings us
closer to people around the world in our
interpersonal communications and it does
the same thing for businesses it means
that the moment you turn yourself on the
Internet everybody on the Internet can
access you okay
and so these businesses are inherently
more global which which creates massive
massive opportunity uncapped opportunity
which is why we see so many of these
consumer tech platform companies become
so valuable so quickly because the world
is their marketplace you know Facebook
you know it's just mind-boggling how big
Facebook has gotten billions of users
and it's because the friction to adding
the enth user is zero there's no
friction at all and so you know I'm a
big believer in taking technology
businesses globally now there are some
places you can't go you know North Korea
and China are difficult in many ways
Japan is difficult for its own or it's
for different reasons you know but
global is a real opportunity I have no I
don't know anything about Japanese real
estate so I can't comment on your second
on your second question all right yes
how do you know what close humor is like
how do you follow and decide understand
what they need okay how do you know what
consumers like okay well there's some
companies that say so Apple if Steve
Jobs were alive he'd say it's art not
science if Mark Zuckerberg were here
he'd say it's science not art I'm right
in between I think it's art and science
I think the art is having user empathy I
only do consumer oriented companies okay
this is different for b2b companies it's
not my not my department
but for consumer oriented companies you
have to have people that have empathy
for the user who understand or can
imagine a real understanding of the
problems and opportunity
and joys and fears and insecurities of
users okay
and paints and and hypothesize big ideas
that will cure those pains and push
those entertainment buttons and light
them up and then that hypothesis is
turned into a product and the wonderful
thing about our technology products is
we have tons of data for how they're
used and that's where the science comes
in that's so that we have art and
science and so you've got to have great
science to be able to look at how
products are being used and make you
know micro and macro changes as quickly
as possible cycling through as quickly
as possible to figure out how to
optimize and how to make these things
work
so it's art and science yeah so we were
talking it was clear that you're
mentioning that your company touched
upon a culture people and technology and
as you are building your culture and
trying to make sure that you go higher
the households where the scumbag yeah
what's your secret awesome finding the
right people for your organization so
that they find writers convenes right
culture I mean I how do you find the
right people to maintain these
successful cultural organizations that
can win you know a little bit of The
Wizard of Oz answer I would give you but
that's not specific I know you know at a
micro level the interview is a really
important thing the interview combined
with references but in a conversation
with someone I always try to get at the
passion and find the person's passion if
I can't find the passion I assume it's
not there and so maybe that's unfair we
only have an hour or whatever but if I
can't find it um when I in it I don't do
a ton of interviewing anymore you know
but I do for high-level jobs and I
always start in the interest part of the
resume
you know this person likes the golf or
snowboard or Ultimate Frisbee or
whatever it is and I start there and I
try to find if that's just that
they're putting down there or if they
actually care about those things if they
care about those things their eyes light
up they lean forward they start they
start thinking they become animated and
now we can have a business conversation
maybe built around that so that's one of
the techniques I use but there's no Pat
answer to that question you've got to
have an organization that continually is
bringing smart people in what attracts
the smart people to apply is great glass
door ratings great glass door ratings
and a clarity of mission and purpose and
a mission that that person is attracted
to and so that person should come in
with that and if you find that and
there's a fit you give them a try if it
doesn't work out don't be afraid to to
say it didn't work out and and move on
[Applause]
you